So this is a sample of osmium. Osmium, again,
is a precious
metal, platinum-group metal, and this is an
osmium sponge
which is very nicely packaged up in this box.
So let’s have a
look and see if we can find it.
So osmium is another one of the elements in
the so-called
‘platinum group’ and it is quite unusual
in that its oxide –
osmium tetroxide is a stable compound which
is really quite
easily evaporated. It has quite a strong smell
which is unusual
for metal compounds and it can be evaporated
quite easily
and it is used in organic chemistry because
if you have
compounds with double bonds between two carbon
atoms,
osmium tetroxide reacts with it really quite
easily.
So here the osmium itself, it is a very, very
reactive metal, it
is sealed in this glass ampule under an inert
atmosphere of
argon so that it can’t oxidise. The argon
is very inert and it
stops the metal reacting. So here you can
see this very dark
black metal, very fine spongy-type material,
at the bottom of
this glass vial.
Again, osmium has played some role in my life
because I did
some of the early work in my doctorate involved
osmium
compound, it was ruthenium and osmium and
iron. The
ruthenium compound was orange, the osmium
compound a
rather fetching pale yellow and the iron compound
a very dark
green. And the osmium compound was perhaps
the most
boring because it behaved in exactly the way
that was
predicted.
So osmium reacts with the air to form osmium
tetroxide,
which is a very, very toxic material, it makes
us go blind so
we have very careful with storing the osmium.
Since then, I think in my life I have made
one osmium
compound that nobody had ever made before,
it wasn’t
enough to see but I could see the absorption
of light by this
compound, so I was really quite excited.
Do you remember what it was it in it?
What?
Do you remember what it was, the compound?
The compound was osmium dicarbonyl dinitrosyl
and it was
interesting because nobody had ever made this
compound
before, but it was similar to a compound of
iron which was
quite well known. The compound of iron looked
like blood; it
was a really quite dramatic compound. I never
found out
what the colour of the osmium compound was,
I never made
enough, but I am not a very good synthetic
chemist.